another thing you were telling me
earlier was that you would much prefer
to have a shark encounter while you're
spearfishing versus if somebody were
surfing if you're a diver you can defend
yourself from a shark a lot better than
a surfer or a swimmer a surfer or a
swimmer or sitting ducks that's why I
don't want to go swimming at New Smyrna
I feel like I've been you know all my
defenses are gone right well even if you
don't have a spear gun knowing you're
diving you think you're a better chance
yeah if you're diving yeah because you
can always hit the shark with your hands
you can charge him if you go out at a
shark swim towards him you frighten him
really you have easy things you're gonna
hurt him so if you swim away from him
he's gonna attack you he thinks you're
praying to get away so the worst thing
to do for a shark is run like crazy away
from then you're gonna instigate an
attack can you pull that video type in
Mick Fanning this is what I was talking
about the guy Mick Fanning was in the
surf for surf contest in Jeffrey's Bay
South Africa and he was sitting out
there waiting for a wave by himself and
all of a sudden you just see him get
pulled under and yeah watch this he's a
sitting duck and you can see the fin
come up I think it was the one of the
saw pectoral fins come on watch them it
grabs his leash like the leash that
connects his foot yeah see he's totally
helpless right there viewers of mask and
fins and a stick in his hand he would
have been able to fight that shark now
watch he starts hauling ass swimming as
fast as he can
yeah that that normally of those like a
creamy recirc or bulls forget him
attacked the great white may not
recruiting would have would would have
come back I don't really know yeah what
kind of shark was that was a great white
wait yeah the bull has to say three
times the job pressure and his bite of a
great white really yeah it's a very bad
bite what would you have done in that
situation if you were him
no I've never been in this swam away
what you would've been surfing right now
I was gonna tell you something before
forget if you're if I'm luring in sharks
for feeding and unscripted meat and
drawing creating a shark feeding frenzy
I'm place safe for doing that and if I
am just randomly
you're fishing because okay you spear
group an old well your heads under the
rock and your feet are hanging out
trying to get the group out of the hole
you want a percent vulnerable this is a
bull shark in the air he's gonna attack
us when he's gonna get you so as a shark
diet if I'm shark diving
I want the Sharks to be there whenever
you're expecting them come you're aware
of them yeah I know you're aware and you
and you can defend yourself because you
you that's all you you're looking out
for them that's selecting you when
you're spearfishing I don't want to see
sharks Yeah right I don't know I'm not
aware because when you're focusing to
get a fish at that moment that's when
the Sharks come out shark likes to bite
when you're not looking at him
like all predators okay these animals
they're looking for a meal now what
makes animals dangerous is how hungry
they are sometimes sharks are not hungry
they're not gonna bother you yeah you
know the hungrier the animal what
motivate motivates a lion or a tiger or
an alligator crocodile or shark to eat
somebody it's how hungry is that animal
how desperate you know when you you're
really really hungry you ready to eat
anything yeah I don't like that food
irena I'd rather have a steak but I'll
eat that rotten hamburger because I'm
really hungry so you there's no
exception when a shark is really hungry
he'll make a meal of what's there people
seen him trying to eat a log in the
ocean they're so hungry
Wow so have you been in a situation
where you're having a shark charge at
you and you try to charge back at it
yeah all my life yeah and so what they
just get they get scared of you charging
back at them what do you do you just run
face-to-face - we do it all the time you
run them off or they steal your fish
yeah you know you run them off or go
bite you don't run from them you can
leave the area but you you got to watch
your back remember he wants a bite when
you know you can defend yourself when
you see it coming same thing with an
alligator here you can levitate a
charging alligator but if you the one
that bit me it was an ambush I never saw
right I was too lazy to look behind me
but if I would have seen him coming I've
had alligators go after me and at the
last minute I get alona water and I
grabbed him by the shin i tilt her head
up and that disrupts her attack it
confuses the alligator
usually do that a couple times it'll
work the attack I had one tried to take
me down ten times before I mean I get a
left of water and then it'll stop but as
long as I was there he kept coming
around he tried to go in underwater at
me on a surface different styles of
attack it was able to block him every
single time on the attack by grabbing
you got to make sure you don't put your
hand in his mouth when he's coming at
you at the last minute you gotta grab
that skin down there I mean don't go try
this on your own I won't yeah I'm not
going unless you do this if also in your
broke down and you're swimming and you
got attacked in the last resort it's
great I know something like that yeah
definitely don't I'm not telling you to
go look for these you know it's kind of
like you know I took karate lessons I'm
gonna go to a bar and pick a fight yeah
somebody will beat your butt or you can
make a shot in the head right something
like that
[Music]
you